have a couple of fairly fast-moving
developments the most recent of which
has just come out this from the
government's legal department sadie yes
and this would be the fourth time that
this case goes before a high court judge
so it's being sent back to the family
division of the high court and i
understand it's being sent
to an out of off um out of hours duty
judge who's expected to respond within
hours he's been he's been asked to look
at this and take into consideration
urgent consideration now it'd be
interesting to know what grounds the
court will look at this in because all
of this comes after a u.n intervention
late on friday
under articles
10 and 12 of the u.n convention of the
rights of persons with disabilities the
family had made that application on
behalf of archie battersby
and the un had imposed an injunction a
non-binding but an injunction
nevertheless on britain
requesting that britain does not
withdraw treatment as is ordered by the
british courts on the
hospital trust
now that became very tricky for the
british government because a um
it seems like uncharted territory legal
experts that we've spoken to have said
that something like this has never
happened the un um has never imposed um
an injunction like this on britain in
such a case and perhaps indicative of
how tricky it was is that it took the
government roughly 24 hours to come back
to us with a statement just to
acknowledge that they'd received that
letter so um
we suspect that there was
some
work to be done to figure out what this
means and as i say completely uncharted
but also very tricky because this case
has been through
three high court hearings already two
appearances at the court of appeal and
once at the supreme court which is the
highest appeals court for civil cases in
the uk so it seems that the case has
exhausted all legal options in the uk
and so for it to now be sent back to the
high court is um very interesting but
also it's interesting because their
latest
judgment we had was in a case about best
interests what is in arch's best
interests and the un
crpd which is the
convention under which the un has
intervened
article 7 of that says that best
interests have to be the primary concern
but of course that's already been done
in a british court so it'll be really
interesting to see
how the high court
progresses with this but a decision has
to be made when it has to be made very
fast because the current order is for
treatment to be withdrawn by 2 pm
tomorrow
and the trust have so far told us that
they plan to go ahead with that and that
it is unlawful for them to continue
treating actually beyond that point and
so they're waiting for a court order to
tell them what to do
but that decision needs to come very
quickly and we expect there may be a
hearing tomorrow